ladies and gentlemen we we've got a
warning from Alex Jones I'm going to
play this clip for you I have no idea
what he's going to say hopefully it's uh
he's warning uh about a terror attack
let's play this clip and see what he
says we've got a great team on the
border right now Chase geyser and some
amazing other people I'm not going to
say their names and they met with good
federal agents today who showed them the
memo that they're saying imminent white
supremacist attacks in Eagle Pass now
whether that's a real threat or not the
point is
good people gave us this information it
fits of the whole Biden narrative to
demonize the American people and to try
to legitimize a totally open border and
all the crime and all the sex traffic
that's happening so obviously we believe
it's probably a false flag there are
some actual crazy people out there as
well in this
whole crisis that America is in right
now I'd say 90% chance that yeah they're
they're probably provocateurs but
regardless this is real Intel this is
real information we've got crew down
there right now we're reporting on it
all and M wars.com for show I'll be on
the air tomorrow 11:00 a.m. Central on
my regular show uh covering it all as
well but our crew is down there at the
border and this comes directly from high
level sources so this is Major breaking
news that the feds have told the major
board Patrol facility uh there in South
Texas prepare for imminent white
supremist Attack On the Border Patrol so
we're getting this out ahead of time
hopefully this exposer will stop it if
it's actually a ro plan I don't know all
the answers I don't know if it's a false
flag I don't know if it's if if it's it
was false info from the feds I don't
know if it's a real I don't know but the
report from the feds and the memo is
100% real so ladies and Gentlemen let's
pray for the board Patrol and others
down there and just thank God we got
eyes and ears on this we're going to
stop this God bless and good luck man I
don't know we do know uh in this story
from Daily Caller ice confirms it
finally nabbed terrorist allowed to roam
free for almost a year the guy who was
in Pennsylvania who uh headed his own
dad was known to the FBI
yeah so I kind of you know I kind of
wonder about these things
but I don't I don't know why anyone
actually aligned with Trump would go and
attack anyone down there I know why the
feds would stage something this is why
you know uh uh looking at everything
going on right now Trump is leading
CNN's projected Trump to win if the
election were to be held today for what
purpose would someone decide to destroy
all of that you're anti-trump and you're
anti-christian if you're doing that like
the guy with the manifesto his father's
severed head he claimed to be Christian
claim to be these guys are all they
they're they're not they're they're not
they're the anti that and they're either
I believe feds or accelerationists who
don't care and they want to just see the
whole country burn so they can step case
I think actually insane might be I'm
still I still don't know because he
could just be ultra like MK Ultra insane
um that would still be crazy though yeah
no matter how he got there that would
mean that he's uh been weaponized by the
government to be in what what about the
guy who was found with all the weapons
right in that what was it like a uh or
something yeah or he said I I I I think
it was a theme park like I I don't want
to do this I didn't want to do this I
just wanted to come here when it was
closed or something like that or the guy
in Maine who K killed all those people
you know who was also yeah well the one
that was just his past fall I believe oh
and he was found in a like box truck the
dumpster outside or something uh but he
killed a lot of people wmart he was also
at a mental institution prior mhm
hearing voices then let loose well there
was that um uh transgender identifying
person I think in Oregon who was uh
arrested before an attack happened but
had been known to the FBI posting all
kinds of things interesting case because
the person was both like biologically
male identified as female and also said
that he had they had been going to white
supremacist rallies with their now
deceased boyfriend it's very story my
gut tells me stuff like this if you are
out there being a part of this if it's
going to happen you are probably being
set up and it's a governor Whitmer
situation where like there's 20 people
and there's two of you and they're going
to destroy you and then use you to
destroy the rest of everyone everyone
else or activists come down and one guy
they don't know shows up because not
everybody knows each other yep starts it
starts some kind of
conflict shows
up look at Occupy Wall Street what what
would happen and I believe it was
actually leftists that would do this I
know they actually had this in their
plans you find a peaceful protest again
far left we we would call them black
block Anarchist at the time now we'
refer to them as antifa because it's
like the the name yeah 50 peaceful
protesters organize a rally saying we
want to we want to hold up signs the
left wants to radicalize them so what
they'll do is they'll have one person
dressed up in all black go into the
middle of the crowd and then Chuck a
rock or a bottle at a cop the cops then
bring out orange netting and wrap
everybody up and arrest all of them then
when all these people you get get some
22-year-old college uh woman she's in
jail crying being like I don't
understand I was just standing there and
then the person who orchestrated goes
you see how evil they are you should
join
us it goes back to what I was saying
earlier about caricatures if you can
convince people of car there's already
the caricature of the Maga extremists
Biden had a whole speech about it
they're the biggest threat this is
confirmation bias for the people who buy
into the caricature it's it's crazy and
I talk to a lot of people about this and
like whether my family who aren't has
plugged in to this world as we might be
and they'll be like how could you even
think that it's grotesque to even
question this it's a terrorist threat
it's a beheading this is awful it is
awful but when you know about things
like operation Northwoods that were
people like The Joint Chiefs of Staff
planning horrible false lags to start a
war with Cuba it makes it so I have to
question anything and I I know I have a
skepticism bias with reality and I'm
very like reluctant to believe anything
that's my own problem but you kind of
have to lead with that in times of War
which I do believe we're we're in a time
of War but what what is a white
supremacist attack I mean we talk about
this like it's a thing like we know what
that they're going to blame it on some
type of contingent that they can match
up with the Justin moan type character
and anyone else from you know j6 who
knows and then talk about it and being
like they're going to go B you know
border patrol but in in the last eight
years and honestly probably more than
that there are only two incidents that
they can even describe as a white
supremacist attack Charlottesville and
January 6th and Charlottesville was
pretty much a nothing burger right uh so
I don't I mean why not just say uh uh
border radicals you know a group of
Border radicals because they've been
selling a certain narrative about magga
extremists who are white supremacists
adjacent you know in their minds and we
might understand that there's been white
supremacist attacks I'm putting that in
quotes for those listening but to them
they think there's been a whole slew of
white supremist attacks this is the FBI
saying it this isn't Alyssa Milano I
mean the FBI is oh my God the white
supremacists are coming well what what
is the I'm going to start referring to
leftists as white supremacists well they
are they legit are but this is the thing
we we we do think they are segregation
the speaking down to black people the
believing black people aren't smart
enough to get IDs they're white
supremacists the thing is whatever our
faction is we try so hard to steal man
and actually honor the arguments but
that doesn't work for the average person
who's apolitical yeah so you know let me
just say that the grinstein are white
supremacists I think they genuinely are
I think anak casparian is a white
supremacist I think she genuinely is and
I'm not trying to be funny I think these
people hold views where they'll deny of
course we're not white supremacists but
if you if you were to bring up like is a
black only space permitted if you made
they're going to say yes and they're
going to make an argument that is
overtly racist they're going to be in
favor of affirmative action what does
affirmative action mean y affirmative
action at like Harvard for instance this
lawsuit an Asian kid at two Asian kids
what the left does is they look at them
both and they go they look like each
other so they're not allowed in school
that's racist that makes no sense you
could get an Asian kid from South
Central who's like not the same culture
as a kid from from China but they're
just like but they look the same so
we're not GNA they're racist they're
white supremacists Mark Cuban is a white
supremacist Mark Cuban is absolutely a
white supremacist I will say this
unequivocally Mark Cuban I hope you hear
this you are a white supremacist you are
I mean he's even he's even reposting all
the these posts from people talking
about jeice thinking he's being clever
by doing it I just think the dude is a
is a deep seated white supremacist his
whole view is that so he he he markk
cubin made this argument that if you
have too many white people you need to
start asking your I mean this is this is
a remarkable white supremacist ARG made
he's like you run a successful business
for five years and you look around and
all your 30 employees are all white so
you think I should hire a black
woman yo you're a white supremacist in
your mind the idea that you're
surrounded by white people with a
successful business I mean think about
where that starts what he is telling you
is his business succeeded on his
predisposition to only hire white people
okay let let let me let me stress this
he is he is he doesn't understand that
he's saying this what he is saying
projection is everything when someone
when someone says something to like uh
I'll tell you I I I I knew this woman
who worked at Fusion when I worked there
and she said to me one time she's like
be be honest with me Tim like how many
of your friends like you're hang out
with the guys like how many of them are
are joking and laughing about like
raping women and I was like are you
kidding me none and she goes no no no
come on be honest like how many and I
was like zero are you are you for real
in her world viiew when she sees guys
she actually thinks they're all having
parties talking about raping women right
genuinely from this feminist narrative
Mark cuin in his mind is
thinking businesses are predisposed to
succeed
with tons of white people working there
I don't have that preconception he's
quite literally the fact that he made
the argument scenario it's been five
years your business business is
successful and you look around and it's
all white guys I'm like okay what makes
you think that's the scenario to choose
from that could be you're in a majority
white neighborhood they exist and then
immediately says I should hire a black
woman yeah cuz you're racist you think
that a black woman's perspective is fun
fundamentally different from a white
person absolutely yeah that's racist
soft bigotry of low expectations I mean
beyond that it's it's the assumption
that uh I shared with him that video I
saw this weekend it's uh from Jubilee
it's awesome six black guys and a white
guy all wearing blindfolds and the goal
is to figure out who the white guy is
and they can't the the white guy talks
and he's from South Central they can't
figure out who he is they vote a bunch
of people off they vote black guys they
vote for black guys to be white they're
like that guy sounds white he's out I
said that to him I'm like imagine you
actually put on a blindfold and tried to
hire the black women or imagine you
looked at a resume and tried to H you
wouldn't be able to you might you might
look down and be like ah they went to
school in South Central they must be
black and then a white guy walks in
you're like huh because that the the the
argument he's making has nothing to do
with it so anyway long story short oh
yeah Mark cubin hands down is a white
supremacist I'm not that's not an
exaggeration either just because there
they're doing the like uh um the royalty
of but we're so much better than they
are the lonely people need our help
that's what he's doing they'd be nothing
without awful that's like an awful
racist yeah they they literally think
that that that you would they need you
to survive yes you should yes also
somebody should clip that segment cuz it
was hilarious while we're at it can
someone make like some pictures of him
in a certain white Hood perhaps Mark
Cuban I think he needs that on I don't
know
about no Tim's not asking for that
that's that's me just s those directly
sh it's better than the Pelosi AI things
I've been I've been getting so you're
still getting them because you love they
slow down they I feel like you're
seeking them out at this point you're
still getting them imagine that's my
thing thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net